ich gebe Ihnen mal
meinen Ausweis
igitt
niemals was ich so ein Scheißding kann
ist so das sind sie
drauf Deutschland
da oben hat aber das Land zu stehen der
Staat Deutschland BRD ist kein Staat
so dann steht da fang reden ihr Name
Chris gut in Ordnung
steht dir so auch in ihrer
Geburtsurkunde
ja nein
da steht er richtig da steht nämlich ein
großes V und dann steht ein kleines an
ein großes R und dann ein kleines Regen
das ist ihr Name das ist nicht ihr Name
das geht weiter sind sie ein freier
Mensch
ich nein
nur Sklaven werden so beschrieben denn
früher die geraubten [ __ ] aus Afrika
oder wie auch immer die kam dann schon
verkauft auf dem Markt das Stande da
große schwarze Tafel Kreide und wie hieß
der Mann
Sun oder jem
in großen Buchstaben
sie sind Sklave also beweise ich ihn
jetzt
gucken Sie mal was sehen Sie da genau wo
ich jetzt hin zeige was sehen Sie dann
müssen wir im Licht so ein bisschen
Punkt ein Punkt
rosa und den haben sie alle und das ist
ihre sklavennummer ihre
sklaven-überwachungsnummer jeder Mensch
weiß derzeit mit der Überwachung dass
sie sie sie alle hier sitzen beim
Kanzler sie sind immer überwacht und
diese ganzen
die Girlanden
Kripo Angelegenheit auch die Person ist
nicht da nicht zu finden und weil es ist
alles Schauspiel alles nur Schauspiel
über den Ausweis den sie bei sich haben
sind sie immer findbar sofort in
Sekunden haben die den Ausgleich geortet
es ist alles Luke und trug
so ist aber alles bekannt sie müssen nur
mal ins Internet gucken